er wagt sich an tabus und liebt kühne
visionen matthias klee ein comic
zeichner der sich mit vorliebe dem
reizthema stadland agglomeration widmet
kein wunder der mann ist auch architekt
das schöne ist dass es wunderbar faul
ist die fantasie erstmals in
fantastischer form 1000 hier und das ist
genau das was mir am meisten spaß machte
den mädchen sind wirklich eine situation
städte situation über den account für
meine geschichte die entwickelt er in
einem zürcher architekturbüro früher
entwarf hier um boten heute vornehmlich
bilderwelten
sein neuester und neunter band behandelt
ein globales problem unseren steigenden
wohnbedarf in die kopierte stadt schlägt
matthias klemm vor wie dieser schnell
gestellt werden könnte durch
originalgetreues nachbilden von intakter
infrastruktur so entsteht zürich in
china ein zweites mal ist das war ein
witz oder einst beides muss alles
wirklich neu ist ich muss alles in der
phoenix see oder kabinett auf sache
zurück riefen funktioniert das hat mich
interessiert will die staatsführer
wunderbar funktionierende stadt hat das
heeres qualität
warum alles neu erfinden nahm er doch
das geht nicht exportieren
serena war
es klingt grotesk matthias kliem lässt
die kopie von zürich als agglomeration
wieder auferstehen und zwar vor den
toren coninx zürichs realer partnerstadt
in china
aber dieser provokative gedanken ist
nicht fernab der realität die rapide
wachsende millionenmetropole plan
tatsächlich einen gürtel mit
satellitenstädten zudem gibt es in china
schon verschiedene kopien von
europäischen architektur ikonen
die viertel sind beliebt bei besuchern
in künstlicher umgebung zu wohnen lehnen
jedoch viele ab etwa in der modernen
version von ordos einer chinesischen
stadt der inneren mongolei in der
monotonie von neue orders hat sich kaum
leben eingestellt obwohl immer mehr
chinesen vom land weg ziehen
sie wollen in die metropolen nicht in
die retortenstadt
fatal wären zwangsumsiedlungen aber die
überlegung durch eine kopierte stadt
rasch wohnraum zu schaffen das sich
anderswo bewährt hat findet matthias
kliem spannend aber das wichtig er
schließe eine schule mit
ich hab's möglichkeiten und ausführungen
gut positioniert madita regionallager
auch sein szenario für die agglomeration
in der schweiz lässt aufhorchen
der 45-jährige dokumentiert
entwicklungen die er dann in seinen
comics aufgeregt wie im glattpark einem
neu entstehen den wohnraum für 20.000
menschen an der zürcher stadtgrenze für
matthias gnehm ist klar das mittelland
wo er selbst aufwuchs verschmilzt zu
einer einzigen heterogenen statt
ich stoppe schaut undicht haben so was
ist nicht dicht bebautes getaut der
preis eben burg die bekehrung aus schwul
bezeichnet das ist
drastische sicheres gespür des studios
und machen gerne über lieber hätte er
aber wenn sich die vision aus die
bekehrung verwirklichen ließe plakate
seiner graphic novel von 2011 skizzieren
das gestern heute und morgen des
mittellands links den einstigen stark
landwirtschaftlich geprägten raum in der
mitte die jetzige zersiedelung und
rechts deren zukünftige entschlackung
eine schweiz die nur noch aus dicht
bebauten städten besteht und
weitläufigem grün die agglomeration ist
verschwunden ist natürlich schön alles
wäre ein grüner wunderbare natur teppich
und dann die einzelnen kompakte steht
für bundes mit der hochbahn ruder laufe
das team hat ihre vision tatsächlich
noch mit den comics kennt aber ich
glaube es löst emotionen aus
tatsache war eine studie war das
tatsächliche möglichkeit für die zukunft
im gegensatz zur architektur muss sich
eine comic geschichte nicht umsetzen
lassen
sie soll denkanstöße liefern
diskussionen los und das leistet das
werk von matthias knien